hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today's gonna be a quick little
video just saying thanks for 5 K subs
really quick my voice may sound really
shitty and different it'd be it might be
because I'm sick I'm not entirely sure
yet I don't feel sick it's just my voice
but oh well
either way although it doesn't seem like
a big number and when I first did
YouTube I thought this would be super
easy and then really quick reality hit
me and I realized that this is way
harder than it looks literally starting
from nothing at zero subs and then
trying to get to something to like where
I am now is incredibly hard and that's
why constantly thank you guys because
without you I'd still be stuck at zero
that's why I try to keep a positive and
chill attitude to keep you guys happy
when you're watching a video of mine and
a lot of you seem to love it I get
comments all the time and the videos on
the streams on the community post saying
I'm a really nice dude that I always
read the chat and stream and I'm always
super chill and that's what I try to do
that was my main goal for that so I just
really want to thank you guys for the
support on my recent videos in the past
couple weeks in a specific these two
right now that are on screen because I
never expected these to do so well but
that was the first that was my first
Monster Hunter video I ever made and
that was a super great way to start back
in for honor I kind of had to grind up a
little bit slowly getting more views as
it went on but one Monster Hunter it was
just a perfect straight shot in the
first video so I'm super happy that went
well thank you guys for that and for the
400 video didn't even better in the
beginning getting 10,000 views and Lily
the first day which usually takes me
around three days to achieve on a normal
depth in video that I do so I'm sorry I
didn't have anything planned like a face
reveal like some people thought I would
do because we hit it so fast and because
I don't have a camera or webcam to use
since I never really need one to begin
with since I just read patch notes and I
don't really obviously use a face cam
for it as a quick update though in the
future I got some more Monster Hunter
videos and the works for you guys like
solo guys and tips for you dudes and for
the majority of my audience for season 5
is right around the corner there's
supposed to be a dev stream like always
on Thursday so glad the recap that it's
probably gonna show more stuff on konk
beserker and ken se as well has some of
the executions that we saw in that photo
from last week so I'll gladly recap that
like I always do for you guys either way
thank you for watching the video if you
guys did enjoy it please give it a like
if you're somehow new and you found this
video then I cover for honor and Monster
Hunter content
if this sounds interesting then
subscribe to most readers are gonna be
on screen if you didn't miss those and
with that guys hope we have a great rest
your day
thank you all for 5k you guys are the
best I'll see you later
peace out